let's say that we have the function g of
x
and it is equal to the definite integral
from 19 to x
of the cube root of t
dt
and what i'm curious about finding or
trying to figure out is what is g prime
of 27 what is that equal to pause this
video and try to think about it and i'll
give you a little bit of a hint think
about the second fundamental theorem of
calculus
all right now let's work on this
together so we want to figure out what g
prime we could try to figure out what g
prime of x is and then evaluate that at
27 and the best way that i can think
about doing that is by taking the
derivative of both sides of this
equation so let's take the derivative of
both sides of that equation so the
left-hand side we'll take the derivative
with respect to x of g of x and the
right-hand side the derivative with
respect to x of all of this business now
the left-hand side is pretty
straightforward the derivative with
respect to x of g of x that's just going
to be g prime of x
but what is the right hand side going to
be equal to
well that's where the second fundamental
theorem of calculus is useful i'll write
it right over here second
fundamental i'll abbreviate a little bit
theorem
theorem
of
calculus
it tells us let's say we have some
function capital f of x
and it's equal to the definite integral
from a some constant a to x
of lowercase f of t
dt
the second fundamental theorem of
calculus tells us that if
our lowercase f if lowercase f is
continuous
on the interval from a to x so i'll
write it this way on
the closed interval from a to x
then
then
the derivative of our capital f of x
so capital f prime
of x
is just going to be equal to our inner
function f evaluated at x instead of t
it's going to become lower lowercase f
of x
now i know when you first saw this you
thought that hey this might be some
cryptic thing that you might not use too
often but we're going to see that it's
actually very very useful and even in
the future and some of you might already
know there's multiple ways to try to
think about a definite integral like
this and you'll learn it in the future
but this can be extremely simplifying
especially if you have a hairy definite
integral like this
and so this just tells us hey look the
derivative with respect to x of all of
this business first we have to check
that our inner function which would be
analogous to our lowercase f here is
this continuous on the interval from 19
to x
well no matter what x is this is going
to be continuous over that interval
because this is continuous for all x's
and so we meet this first condition or
our major condition and so then we could
just say all right then the derivative
of all of this is just going to be this
inner function replaced replacing t with
x so we're going to get the cube root
instead of the cube root of t you're
going to get the cube root of x
and so we can go back to our original
question what is g prime of 27 going to
be equal to what's going to be equal to
the cube root of 27 which is of course
equal to 3 and we're done